sie ist es etwas düster wie die zukunft
aussieht ob beziehungsweise wie die
regierung mit uns bürgern umgeht zum
einen würde ich mich erstmal dem
anschließend was die drei ja nicht
gerade gesagt hat dass die
wirtschaftliche situation sicherlich
überhaupt nicht gut ist und die frage ob
es proteste gibt und der andere sagt ja
schon das werden proteste seien die vor
allem ostdeutschland stattfinden gibt
auch eine innenministerin die denen die
da protestieren werden leicht den
stempel rechts und rechtsradikal
aufdrückt so weit würde ich überhaupt
nicht gehen aber was ich schon
feststelle ist oder was wir feststellen
müssen glaube ich dass wir
eine neue krise haben wir erst corona
jetzt haben die energiekrise wenn eine
neue regierung ist die gruppe jetzt die
ampel aber die verhaltensmuster seit
corona offenbar doch die gleichen sind
denn wir in uns alle an das fast schon
übergriffigen oder das übergriffige muss
man sagen des staates wieder statt in
der korona pandemie anfänge bis ins
kleinste detail das leben der bürger zu
bestimmen da durfte ab 22 uhr nicht mehr
zusammen getalkt werden und alleine
durfte man nur ab zwischen mitternacht
und fünf uhr morgens gar nicht mehr
joggen gehen für ein paar monate da
wurde festgelegt wie viele kinder zu
kindergeburtstagen noch erscheinen
dürfen da ganz eine grenze von zehn von
der masken pflicht möchte ich gar nicht
sprechen also da wurde bis ins kleinste
detail das leben der bürger geregelt und
was die folge war das war natürlich
proteste auf der straße und das sehen
wir jetzt wieder die bundesregierung in
form der ampel hat heute auch zwei
pakete sogar
verabschiedet zwei verordnungs pakete
gesetzespakete dass eine wieder zu
corona das andere zum thema energie
sparen wenn man da genau anschaut dann
sieht man auch wieder viele dinge wo man
sagen muss hier wird der staat
übergriffig und macht dinge die ihnen
nicht zustehen beispielsweise
beleuchtung beleuchtung in geschäften
nina schenk hat das gerade schon
angesprochen
von 22 uhr bis 16 uhr ist es ab
september untersagt für geschäftsleute
leuchtwerbung zu scheiden das muss man
sich mal vorstellen da darf man keine
werbung mehr anmachen die leuchtet um
energie zu sparen und ab september ist
beispielsweise auch geschäftsleute und
hier sitzt eine
inhaberin eines friseursalons mit am
tisch ist es untersagt die türen
dauerhaft offen zu lassen die müssen
also geschlossen sein als wenn jemand
der kaufmann ist und vielleicht das
geschäft sogar ein zweiter oder dritter
generation betreibt nicht weiß wie man
geld zusammenhält wie man spart also
robert habeck der noch in der freien
wirtschaft gearbeitet hat der muss jetzt
kommen und menschen die seit jahren in
der freien wirtschaft arbeiten zu sagen
wie sie energie sparen sollen das ist
übergriffig und
den vogel hat heute herrn karl
lauterbach abgeschossen beim thema
masken pflicht auf die frage warum
eigentlich in
regierungsflieger
politiker ohne maske fliegen dürfen ganz
normalen vorgang das muss ich erst noch
mal sagen ja ganz normale bürger aber
auf der linie oder ferienflug mit maske
fliegen müssen und diese masse nicht er
ist heute noch mal verschärft darauf auf
diese frage ist hat karl lauterbach
geantwortet
[Musik]
es ist ebenso es gibt eigene regeln für
die luftwaffen flugbereitschaft und die
sind hierzu zum einsatz gekommen und
über diese regeln hinaus sind dann
diejenigen den mitgereisten noch
getestet worden es ist eben so sagt karl
lauterbach es ist eben so meine damen
und herren die zuschauer das hat
spaltung potenzial absolut also diese
über griffigkeit dieser hochnäsigkeit
diese doppelmoral und diese arroganz von
karl lauterbach in diesem fall die sorgt
dafür dass das land gespalten wird und
genau diese auch maßnahmen sind es dass
die menschen auf die straße gehen werden
die ampel tut also das gegenteil von dem
was sie eigentlich will sie führt nicht
zusammen sondern sie spaltet er einen
schritt was würden sie entgegnet sie
eine harsche kritik der ampel also was
corona angeht nehmen wir jetzt im
wesentlichen maßnahmen zurück wir werden
im parlamentarischen verfahren auch noch
mal genau hinschauen ich zumindest
persönlich dass die kinder wirklich
vollständig ausgenommen werden dass man
nicht einfach sagen könnt ihr müsst
jetzt maske aufsetzen weil wir lust zu
haben jetzt hat der 5 das ist dann
wirklich einen grund geben dass das
gesundheitssystem wirklich nachweisbar
überlastet ist vor ort und nicht dass
man dann sagt oh jetzt oktober ist kalt
die maske muss auf den würde ich auf
jeden fall widersprechen und herr
lauterbach mit seinem es ist einfach so
was empfinden sie da aber als bürger
herz nicht mehr als politik glaube er
hat nur in dem fall würde ich ihnen
sogar ausnahmsweise verteidigen ich bin
jetzt nicht ein großer freund gewesen
seiner kommunikation weil er einfach die
regelung geschrieben hat die ist ja so
aber ob die so richtig ist dass es ja
und ob die fair und gerecht ist im
verständnis der bürger da würde ich
sagen nein natürlich ist das ein bild
was nicht gut ist wenn auf der einen
seite alle gewisse pflichten haben auf
der anderen dann und da kommt ja dann
auch schnell die idee die da oben die
nehmen sich die eigenen regeln das ist
kein bild das gut ist und das muss man
dann einfach auch so sagen dass das
nicht gut ist wenn ich einmal einen
haken dass beim thema masken pflicht in
schulen
das was die ampel auch dort beschlossen
hat ist ja keine pflicht sondern ist ja
eine empfehlung und man kann dann wenn
die lehrer der meinung sind hier droht
eine schulschließung zu einer masken
pflicht kommen aus eigener erfahrung
kann ich ihnen sagen und ich habe eine
sehr hohe und gute meinung von von
lehrern weil die sehr engagiert sind in
der regel an den schulen herrscht eine
angst vor corona das auch jetzt bereits
es so etwas wie eine maske pflicht gibt
zumindest an berliner schulen das geht
dann so weit dass schüler im unterricht
und die fälle gibt es die keine maske
tragen von einem lehrer der maske trägt
in die letzte reihe gesetzt wenn der
herr steckte masken diskriminierung und
deswegen glaube ich dass ist dass wir
spätestens zum ersten oktober
eine welle von masken pflichten an den
schulen sehen werden wenn ich sogar
schon vorher weil einfach in den schulen
an die anlage herrscht ein sagen wir im
februar 2020 werden und nicht im herbst
oder spätsommer des jahres 2022 und die
meisten 3 oder 4 fach kämpft sind ja ich
habe selber drei kinder an diversen
schulen unterschiedlichster art und
diese kultur der angst die hat
geherrscht und ich hoffe sie wird jetzt
ein stück weit aufgebrochen
sie immer noch nach wie vor herrscht
aber es gibt ja das würde ich jetzt auch
ein gewöhnungseffekt weil viele menschen
die zum beispiel angst hatten dass sich
kinder infizieren gemerkt haben dass
gott sei dank bei den allermeisten
kindern dass keine schweren verläufe
gibt und übrigens jetzt auch mit omikron
variante auch bei älteren wenn sie denn
geimpft sind vor allem das hilft
natürlich dann die schweren verläufe
ausbleiben schön ist es nicht ich hatte
auch corona mich hat es nicht ganz so
hart erwischt meine frau ein bisschen
stärker andere haben es noch stärker
gehabt aber man gewöhnt sich doch an der
mur steuerpolitik ich muss es für die
noch mal sein weil mich das auch maßlos
ärgert mich das war keine kinder aber es
ärgert mich trotzdem maßlos als begonnen
muss denn die ampel und dirigiert nummer
jetzt nicht endlich was dagegen tun
gegen diese masken diskriminierung bei
kindern was das beispiel was jan schäfer
jetzt wir kriegen jeden tag zuschauer
post darüber dass eltern anschreiben
kinder müssen im bus weil der busfahrer
ist möglich die kinder müssen in der
schule wir mussten dann auch testen auf
dem flur damit schön jeder sieht wer
auch nicht geben so weiter es passiert
so vieles gab denkzettel wenn jemandem
maske nicht getragen musste er ausfüllen
warum nicht muss die ampel da nicht mal
ganz entschieden vielleicht sogar eine
pressekonferenz geben an die lehrer ab
man kann auch nicht immer sagen es
sollte nicht so sein aber die kinder
trifft immer noch also erstens glaube
ich sonst nicht die lehrer sondern teile
der verbandsvertreter innen die dort
unterwegs sind und sehr scharf sind wenn
ich nur eine meidinger denke der
übrigens mein sozialkundelehrer aus der
schule in niederbayern war wir kennen
uns persönlich aber sind nicht einer
meinung in dieser frage wie man haben am
kommenden montag habe ihn getroffen vor
einigen wochen auf einem privaten fest
und wir haben dann aber nicht darüber
gesprochen
weil ich mir nicht angemessen schien und
er hat ja öffentlich auch schon manchmal
gehört dass ich ihm widersprochen habe
aber ich würde schon sagen es herrschte
eine angst kommunikation auch in den
schulen die viele menschen traumatisiert
hat und das ist auch ein versagen von
politik kommunikation aber auch von
medien kommunikation gewesen weil man
risikoeinschätzung irgendwann ja auch
mal einordnen muss und nicht der faktor
1000 dann in den köpfen höher ist als
areal ist und ich bin der meinung das
hat vielen geschadet und jetzt wissen
wir doch dass wir doch gut und sicher
mit den kindern durch den winter kommen
es wird vergeben es mit infektionen
geben meine kinder waren schon zweimal
durch das alles nicht schön aber es ist
ja auch keine alternative da also wollen
ein normales
jan schäfer zugehört hat und ich stimme
da auch zu nehmen sie nicht wahr dass
über griffigkeit herrschen dass sich der
staat zu sehr in private entscheidung
eingemischt hat es gibt sicherlich teile
der politischen klasse
nur der politischen klasse auch teile
der medienvertreter teile der
verbandsvertreter die ich würde mal
sagen im ersten jahr gestehe ich allen
alles zu da hatte ich würde ich auch
sagen weil ich wieder lockdown und so
weiter und auf den zweiten aber
irgendwann muss man ja mal in richtung
eigenverantwortung und sagen drei mal
impfen war möglich wir mal von mir aus
auch wenn ihr wollt maske tragen könnte
also irgendwann muss man ja mal auch das
nach ist politik sagt als gesellschaft
sagen wir haben jetzt alles getan ihr
habt alle instrumente da und wir können
jetzt nicht über die köpfe von vielen
die auf der welt sehr großes befremden
haben weiter entscheiden dass wir tief
mikromanagement machen eingreifen und da
sind wir noch nicht ganz raus und
deutsch spanisch und werden sie
zerstören trat im positiven sinn
leitbild vor den grün ich darf ja ganz
ehrlich sagen wie das ist die passende
nicht so richtig rein gebe ich zu ich
glaube manche grüne haben einfach
gewisse freude dran das leben von
menschen sowie der micro mit management
ob das jetzt krone ist oder ob das jetzt
die gelegenheit und nägel christ
waschlappen anstatt durch das ist ja so
ähnlich wie bei manchen religion ja die
auch so den menschen gern mit teil
vorschreiben was sie jeden tag zu tun
und zu lassen haben und das ist nicht
nur bei den grünen da gibt es auch
manche beiden sozialdemokraten bei den
link bei anderen auch ja das war ein
bisschen das problem klar habe ich der
staat solle sich mal darauf
konzentrieren was seine eigentliche
aufgabe ist ein oft versagt ja wir haben
die bundeswehr den schrotthaufen ist ja
wir haben die digitalisierung vollkommen
verschlafen ja da gibt es noch viele
baustellen die wir alle aufzählen
könnten statt immer in das alltagsleben
der menschen schaden löcher und ich
glaube einfach wirklich zerstören sie
gerne meine meinung aller können sie
auch vielleicht nicht so auf das
angestaubt manche von ihren grünen
parteifreunden die anderen dänische
freude denn es macht richtig spaß das
kann man den leuten wieder etwas
vorschreiben so und das ist also sein
motorrad man hört die spaß daran haben
und da sag ich jetzt einfach auch mal so
ganz pauschal weil es auf ihr
parteiprogramm einziehen ja dass man den
reichen jetzt den reichen auch das ganz
bewusst gesagt jetzt den pool aus stellt
das muss man sich mal überlegen was
spart das eigentlich genau an gast wenn
robert habeck sagt die zwei prozent die
wir dann zu sich an gast zur verstromung
brauchen weil wir die kernkraftwerke
abschalten das ist nicht das problem ja
wieviel gas sparen wieder eilig weil
weder irgendwie 1000 pool sky stellen
dass es in 0,000 bereich der aber gast
die macht es gibt zwei millionen watt
puls so ganz wenigstens das nicht hat
das war schon dass sie überhaupt die
grünen sich da einmischen aber das zielt
genau darauf ein den menschen zu sagen
was sie zu tun haben was sie nichts zu
tun haben die wird ist das stichwort
also am besten auch gar nicht mehr auto
fahren nur noch irgendwie im
kollektivistischen transportmittel bahn
unterwegs sein das ist genau das die
heizung runter licht aus fröhlich aus
irgendwann wird es dazu kommen dass auch
im privaten ol
dp mit kerze an warum machen sie es mit
weil sie keine alternative zur zeit
haben die fdp aussteigt verlieren ein
drittel der abgeordneten ihren sitzplatz
ist noch immer kein geld soll und wenn
die spd auf steigt stellt jetzt mit dem
bundeskanzler nicht mehr denn dann
könnten beispielsweise grüne und auch
die fdp geht es in kleinen
mit einem kanzler in der bams
beispielsweise dann regieren die grünen
sind eigentlich in der besten position
muss man das sagen deswegen ist das zur
zeit der stark gemacht faktoren eine
ampel schwachsinn spd und fdp aber spd
müsste eigentlich gar nicht schwach sein
spd hat er sogar den kanzler gestellt
also geht es der politik eigentlich nur
darum seinen sitz zu behalten wenn man
ihn einmal hat egal was jetzt also fdp
hat man gesagt lieber nicht regieren als
falsch reagieren dementsprechend fragt
man sich aktuell schon mal wie lange die
fdp das jetzt mitgeht oder wann sie
finde dass es falsch regieren ist oder
aber die option aus einer koalition
auszusteigen die fdp war schon extrem
schwierigen lage zwischen 2009 und 2013
nicht ausgestiegen die partei jetzt fast
zerrissen in der frage muss man
griechenland unterstützen muss
griechenland im euro bleiben oder eben
nichts gab ein parteiwechsel wechsel an
der spitze also da war richtig was los
und dann hat es sie aus dem parlament
geflogen diese lehre war für die fdp
oder diese erfahrung extrem heilsam und
es gibt immer holen und tief muss man
auch sagen wer weiß wie es im halben
jahres vielleicht sind die grünen ein
bisschen schwächer wieder die fdp ein
bisschen stärker die spd gar nicht
schnell aber es macht aus politischer
sicht nicht aus sicht des weder sage ich
gar nicht aber aus politischer sicht aus
sicht derjenigen die jetzt für die fdp
beispielsweise im bundestag sitzen und
da ein mandat haben macht es eigentlich
wenig sinn rauszugehen weil es
einerseits auch bei einigen
glaubwürdigkeit kostet bei anderen
vielleicht nicht aber falls es zu
neuwahlen kommen sollte und das wäre
sicherlich etwas was die grünen dann
anstreben würden die union mit
sicherheit auch dann müsste in der fdp
die jetzt bei 7 prozent um frank steht
oder viele der abgrund damit rechnen
dass sie nicht mehr im bundestag komme
die unter spd wer ist genauso weiß sind
übrigens aussagen ab und an da muss ich
einmal fragen ich sehe sie manchmal so
ein bisschen schmunzeln um ihre lippen
wobei schmunzeln sie so genau und haben
sie denn lust am verbieten die grünen
was wir hier sehr vehement vorwerfen
robert habeck würde ich sagen ist ein
sehr liberaler politiker also als
wirtschaftspolitiker tut er ja schon das
was jetzt notwendig ist und beschafft
zum beispiel das gas von kanada
vielleicht auch noch katar weil sich
nicht auf jeden fall ist er auf der welt
unterwegs und bringen an begleiten sind
liberaler politiker der furcht deshalb
zigaretten sie gewusst dass das muss ich
einfach mal sagen ein liberaler
politiker der vorschreibt wann ein
unternehmer leuchtwerbung schalten darf
der vorschreibt dass ein unternehmer die
türen zu seinem geschäft nicht auf abend
unter uns entschuldigen ist ja nicht
erst april liberal und staatssozialismus
des passten wir müssen halt die 20
prozent das ist der mann zwar
pragmatismus wir brauchen halten
einsparungen und dann muss man auch ein
paar vorgaben machen und das ist ja
jetzt nicht das schlimmste für die
wirtschaft dass die nachts dann die
beleuchtung aus das ist der
kollektivismus den die gründer sie sind
sie sehen dann sind dann bleiben wir da
eine touristische aufgabe würde mich
selber zum beispiel auch als liberal und
grünen alles ist okay wenn sie
unternehmer vorschreibt so die
leuchtreklame oben der firmenname bleibt
jetzt aus muss ich ja nur machen weil
wir die 20 prozent einschalten das
haben wir überhaupt einmal weiß ich
nicht
dann gehe ich davon aus dass wir die
ausstellung kurz unterbrechen die habe
ich noch eine frage ich wollte sagen die
koalition ist stabil werden keine
neuwahlen und so weiter deswegen habe
ich gespannt
duncan spielrein wäre ist der denkbar da
nehmen wir die nächste wahl zum kanzler
harbeck und vizekanzler märz also ist ja
noch lange hin aber dass die grünen beim
letzten mal schon angestrebt haben die
kanzlerschaft das wird sich beim
nächsten mal nicht ändern so wird das
sein wäre dann der kandidat sein wird
wenn wir sehen